THEM ANOTHER OPTION.
SARA SIDNER HAS MORE.
>> THIS IS THE ALTERNATIVE.
>> IT'S LIKE AN AIRBAG FOR A
BULLET.
>> IT LOOKS LIKE A TOY THAT
ATTACHES TO A REAL GUN, BUT IT'S
NOTHING TO PLAY WITH.
THE NEW DEVICE IS INTENDED TO
GIVE A SUSPECT ONE LAST CHANCE
TO LIVE.
>> PUT THE KNIFE DOWN, SIR!
>> Reporter: WHEN POLICE DECIDE
THE SITUATION IS DANGEROUS
ENOUGH TO USE LETHAL FORCE.
>> IT WAS CREATED BY A RETIRED
SHERIFF'S OFFICER.
HE DID NOT LIKE THE FACT THAT
PEOPLE WERE BEING SHOT WHEN THE
OFFICERS HAVE TIME, BUT NO OTHER
OPTION THAN LETHAL FORCE.
>> Reporter: THE MAKERS SAY IT'S
FOR USE ONLY WHEN AN OFFICER HAS
THREE SECONDS OR MORE TO REACT.
WHAT DOES IT DO TO THE BODY?
>> IT WILL BE LIKE GETTING HIT
WITH A HAMMER.
>> THE BULLET TRAVELS ABOUT 1/5
THE SPEED OF A BULLET.
>> CAN IT KILL YOU?
>> THERE'S A POSSIBILITY IT
COULD KILL YOU, BUT IT'S VERY
SLIGHT WHEN YOU COMPARE IT TO A
BULLET.
>> Reporter: AFTER NINE YEARS IN
DEVELOPMENT, IT'S READY.
IT COMES AS POLICE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY FACE INTENSE SCRUTINY
AND POST OVER THE KILLINGS OF
UNARMED SUSPECTS.
SO FAR, THERE IS ONLY ONE POLICE
DEPARTMENT IN AMERICA THAT HAS
DECIDED TO TEST THE DEVICE.
FERGUSON, MISSOURI.
YES, THAT FERGUSON.
THE DEPARTMENT THAT BECAME THE
CATALYST FOR NATIONWIDE PROTESTS
AGAINST POLICE TACTICS, AFTER
ITS OFFICER SHOT TO DEATH
UNARMED TEENAGER MICHAEL BROWN.
>> WHY IS FERGUSON LOOKING AT
THIS DEVICE?
>> THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE
JUST HAPPENED TO RUN ACROSS.
ESPECIALLY CONSIDERING THE
OUTCRY ABOUT SAVING LIVES.
EVEN LIVES OF PEOPLE THAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO APPREHEND.
THAT THIS MIGHT BE SOMETHING
THAT WAS WORTH LOOKING INTO.
>> BUT SOME FORMER LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS HAVE HUGE
RESERVATIONS ABOUT IT, SAYING IT
COULD DO MORE HARM THAN GOOD,
ESPECIALLY TO OFFICERS.
>> THESE SITUATIONS ESCALATE
VIRTUALLY INSTANTANEOUSLY.
IF YOU HAD SUCH A DEVICE
AVAILABLE, TO BE QUITE FRANK
WITH YOU, YOU COULD NOT
TRANSITION TO LETHAL FORCE FAST
ENOUGH TO SAVE YOUR LIFE.
>> THE MAKERS OF THE ALTERNATIVE
SAY THEIR TESTS SHOWS OTHERWISE.
THE DEVICE ONLY WORKS FOR THE
FIRST SHOT.
INTENDED TO STOP, NOT KILL A
SUSPECT.
BUT IF THAT DOESN'T WORK, THE
GUN IS READY TO FIRE LETHAL
ROUNDS IN A SPLIT SECOND.
EVERYTHING DISENGAGES FROM THE
WEAPON AND THE OFFICER IS READY
TO GO WITH THE BULLETS WHEN
NEEDED.
>> HOWEVER THE DEVICE HAS NOT
BEEN TESTED IN REAL-LIFE
SITUATIONS ON REAL HUMAN BEINGS.
WITH THE OUTCRY OF POLICE
TACTICS, FOR NOW, IT'S